guten morgen freunde wir sind gerade
beim support die da angekommen wo wir
gestern auch schon im trampolin baums be
ok springen waren heute werden wir mit
einer zip line also das ist an sondern
allein ich zeige euch der film das ist
soll alleine da werden wir gleich dran
geschnallt kriegen sein anzug an und
fliegen dann mit 100 km/h mit 100 meilen
pro stunde also das sind 140 km h oder
so fliegen wir erfahren sie dann so
einen berg runter und da versuche ich
was zu film ich versuche eine kamera die
hand zu nehmen
ob die rund da vergleicht nicht ins neue
jahr das gleich wieder gerade und fahren
jetzt hier den bergen wo wir gleich mit
helm fahren
140 hängt an einer leine
mal schauen ob ich das wird der kauf
kommt film könnt ja wir sind hier gerade
am mount everest
dann haben wir unter anderem auch das
haus vom hobby gefunden das sieht sich
umgezogen manchmal auch wenn man ganz
genau hinschaut da vorne bis nach
frankfurt gucken
die hochhäuser dahinten das ist glaube
ich nicht zu verfehlen wir sind jetzt
oben auf dem berg angekommen
ich weiß nicht ob man hier sehen die da
fliegen wir gleich runter und überall
berge und einfach eine mäßige aus sich
die meisten nicht versteht weil es
mischen bin ich dass da hinten sind seen
berge denn sind berge da unten fahren
solche leute fahrer da unten sind die
bmx-fahrer man kann ja auf jeden fall
richtig viel schwachsinn machen wenn man
genug zeit hatte abgezogen ich weiß ohne
helm
wir haben jetzt die nächste zip line
erreicht hat ich glaube das kommt der
kameramann nie so rüber aber es geht
ich denke 40 kilometer weit runter
ein
freunde das war die schnellste plan auf
der wir waren jeweils über ich glaube
waren locker zu 120 km h schnell also
ich hab echt kurzzeitig so gedacht so
auffahrt ich bin viel zu stellen damit
ich nach vorne schauen und so richtig
weit nach oben jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht genau gesehen weil ich aus mir
noch den aufnahmeknopf gekommen aber
vielleicht habe ich einen drauf
wir waren jetzt gerade auf der zip line
und werden jetzt zum strand fahren aber
nicht so wie der strand gestern das ist
der stand es gibt keinen strand hier es
war richtig heiß es war zwar teilweise
wirklich so ein bisschen anstrengen muss
nicht sagen weil ich habe mich die ganze
zeit gedreht einmal und dadurch dass ich
den kammern ärgerte war ich nicht in der
lage mich festzuhalten um weiter
geradeaus zu fahren maxi fandest du das
wir gehen jetzt an strand freunde
schauen jetzt mal ob wir vielleicht
irgendwann surfboard finden ob irgendwo
volleybälle finden irgendwas dann im
büro post mit und gehen dann
wahrscheinlich das schwimmen obwohl es
kalt ist ich werde jetzt ins wasser
gehen junge niemals ich da rein
etwas älter wir waren grad im wasser
nach ihr ahnt es nicht das war echt
nordsee es nichts dagegen dass waren
glaube ich so 21 waren tatsächlich so 8
grad vielleicht auch wenn wir länger
unter wasser gewesen wären
ich hab euch jetzt mal mit hier ins
wasser genommen also es ist wirklich ist
es ja klar aber es ist einfach arschkalt
also jetzt gerade schon relativ warmen
wieder weil wir gerade schon drin waren
aber vor ich freue mich jetzt doch
irgendwie schön auch von kaffee oder
kaffee und tückischen chipsets tot das
war richtig heiß also max es gerade auf
toilette könnte ihn finden
richtig da ist max
durch andere quellen verquicke ich auch
noch immer groß